ضرب اردوغان عصفورين بحجر واحد نال
الرئاسه والبرلمان من جهه وادخل المعارضه
في دوامه من الفوضى من جهه اخرى الا ان
الاقتصاد تركي سيكون اكبر تحديات الرئيس
وهو الذي وضعه على راسي اولوياته في وعوده
الانتخابيه
مع خفض اسعار الفائده سينخفض التضخم مشكله
التضخم ليست اسعار البطاطا او الطماطم او
الباذنجان او المواد الاخرى القضيه
الرئيسيه هي اسعار الفائده التغيير
الرئيسي سياتي من هناك
التحديات التضخم بلغ بحسب الارقام الرسميه
اربعه واربعين في المئه بينما اكدت معاهد
مستقله ان الرقم اعلى بكثير اكثر من الضعف
105% ارقام شهدت هذه ثلاث دول في التاريخ
الارجنتين زيمبابوي فنزويلا وبينما تعالج
كل الدول ازمه التضخم برفع اسعار الفائده
لاردوغان اسلوب اخر خفض اسعار الفائده الى
ثمانيه فاصله خمسه الشهر الماضي من 19%
عام 2019 خطوه وصفها الخبراء بصب الزيت
على النار لكن هل تسعى انقره وراء خفض
قيمه الليره كلما انخفض سعر الليره كلما
كانت اسعار المنتجات التركيه اقل في
الاسواق العالميه وهو ما يرفع من قيمه
الصادرات لكن ومع اقتراب الانتخابات زادت
اهميه القدره الشرائيه للاطراك اردوغان
رفع الرواتب بنسبه 50% وهو سبب اخر للتضخم
كذلك مليارات الدولارات من اجل الحفاظ على
اسعار صرف الليره قبل الانتخابات وهنا جاء
الدور على استنزاف احتياط الصرف وهنا تحدي
اخر
تركيا مؤشرات اقتصاديه متضاربه بعد اعلان
نتائج الانتخابات وفوز اردوغان بولايه
الرئاسيه جديده
فرغم ارتفاع مؤشرات بورصه اسطنبول بنسبه
قاربت اربعه في المئه انخفضت الليره
التركيه مقابل الدولار الى
20.18 حيث يتوقع محلل بنك مورجان ستانلي
ان الليره سوف تنخفض الى 28 مقابل الدولار
الواحد في نهايه العام
ويعزو محللون هذا التراجع الى ضخ البنك
المركزي الاموال قبل الانتخابات للحفاظ
على سعر الصرف في مقابل هذه الانباء ذكرت
مصادر مقربه من الرئيس التركي انه يريد من
وزير الماليه الاسبق والاقتصادي المرموق
محمد شمشك تولي الملف الاقتصادي لكن
شيمشيك يريد حريه اتخاذ القرارات دون تدخل
من احد ويبدو ان الجانبين اتفقا على معظم
النقاط وان شمشك سيكون ضمن التشكيله
الوزاريه الجديده لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات